good morning Hank it's Tuesday so today
I want to announce a new project but
first I have to begin by explain for the
last couple years I have been the
manager of a fictional soccer team
called the Swindon Town swooty poopers
Sicily poopers are led by two Time Lords
both named John Green who are married to
each other and everything was going
swimmingly but then I got obsessed with
recreating the past like Gatsby and I
got fired and now after careful
consideration I've decided to retire
from semi-professional FIFA playing and
I would like to take this opportunity to
announce that I will no longer be
supporting my family in part by playing
video game soccer
however Hank there's a couple things you
need to understand about English
football first if you're in the major
leagues of English soccer we just got
the Premier League in you have a really
bad season and you finish in the bottom
three you don't get to play in the
Premier League next year you are
relegated to the league below that which
helpfully is called the championship you
know because it doesn't feature any of
the champions anyway in every league the
top teams get promoted up each season
and the bottom teams get relegated down
to the weak below and if you could
relegated from the fourth tier which is
helpfully called Ligue 2 then you are no
longer in the Football League and your
team is not even in FIFA anymore
this next English football fun and also
terrifying because there is a lot at
stake every season for every team and no
team experience these crazy highs and
lows more than Wimbledon FC which for
most of its history was in the lower
leagues but then out a run in the top
flight and I mean they won the FA Cup in
1988 now the other big difference
between English football in American
sports is that there are no franchises
so like rich owners can't just move the
Dodgers from Brooklyn to Los Angeles
because they wanna except occasionally
when they can in 2002 Wimbledon FC was
moved to Milton Keynes leaving thousands
of Wimbledon fans without a club I mean
they had a hundred years of history and
then nothing their stadium was torn down
their FA Cup was sent to Milton Keynes
all those later returned so these fans
responded by starting a club from
scratch AFC Wimbledon and they started
in 2002 in the ninth tier of English
football but then they went on this
amazing run in just nine years later in
2011 their captain Danny Cadwell found
himself with one penalty kick to send
Wimbledon to the Football League it's
not I said well laboriously press the
press I think this Philippe soo is 30k
Wow
so AFC Wimbledon became a league to team
which means that you can play them in
FIFA last year they almost got relegated
but then in the last game they won
heroically AFC Wimbledon is a truly
extraordinary football club it's owned
and run by its fans I mean there's no
big money behind it their Chairman is a
retired accountant they were the first
club in England to have a football fans
Against Homophobia banner at a game
basically it's the most awesome Football
Club in the world and I want to help
them stay in the football league so I'm
gonna play with them in FIFA 14 but I'm
gonna keep my vow not to be a
professional FIFA player anymore instead
all ad revenue from the videos will go
to sponsor the actual real AFC Wimbledon
team we're gonna have billboards in the
stadium and ads in the program all
designed by nerdfighters and hopefully
we're gonna help this team that mirrors
the values of nerdfighteria stay in the
Football League so I can play with them
in FIFA 15 and FIFA 16 and beyond and
maybe one day we can send them to the
Premier League now that might be
dreaming but in 2002 when AFC Wimbledon
was playing away games in front of 80
fans it took some dreaming to imagine a
world in which they would be a team that
you could play in FIFA so nerdfighters
do you want to help please subscribe to
Hank games and watch the videos you can
click on my face or this link in the
doobly-doo and let's start designing
some ads together there's more info
below where you can also find videos of
AFC Wimbledon's short but glorious
history Trank I like this new little
project dftba
I'll see you on Friday